can you go into the difference between
being a strong confident female that
won't deal with losers versus the
feminist mindset
there is a difference yeah there is a
difference that's a really good point
um i think confident in the sense of her
femininity and her usefulness as a woman
to enter the man's frame
is probably the way that i would look at
it versus the i don't need no man you
know narrative
what do you think rola um yeah and i
think it
uh one of the things that we sort of
lose sight of right now at least in
in the manner there's guys that will
um will critic they'll say well you know
role has this daughter and
she's in the pageants and blah blah blah
and therefore she you know he's
he's allowing her to to get involved and
all that kind of stuff and she's just
you know she just wants attention and
attention i'm going my
my daughter doesn't have an only fans
right okay she's not making money off of
her sexuality right now and she never
will do that
and you know why because she's part of
the pageant system
that's exactly why it teaches girls
confidence it teaches them to like
it teaches them point you want to know
what's funny to me is we always
criticize women for not having like
like you need to develop femininity
right the end
or we'll say well you can still be
feminine you could be strong like
there's a strength there
is a certain strength of femininity well
you're never going to realize that
unless you can embrace femininity as a
positive
and you know you know where women get
that certainly in pageant systems right
now
it's not just girls prancing around and
you know evening dresses and
and the occasional swimsuit like there's
a lot that goes along with that they
have to have a platform
they have to have some sort of like
public interest they have to
you're going to do better if you're in
college you're going to do better if
you've got a charity
you're going to do better if you know
how to hold yourself and hold a
conversation
how to how to like publicly speak how to
there's so much that goes along with
that that nobody really sees
but that develops a confident female
right there's no what's wrong with
conflict there's a song what's wrong
with being confident right
in fact if anything they oversell that
and so i think what a lot of guys do is
they think that that they
they want little house frows or they
want like if she's not if she's
if she's too confident then she has to
be a feminist
but if she's confident and she's not
like like over you know foaming at the
mouth you know
lena dunham kind of feminist and there's
i think we look at things in two
different extremes and particularly in
the manosphere right now we look at them
in extremes
and in the trad con spheres we look at
them in in the extremes like if she's
if she's lena dunham then she's a
feminist but if she's candace owens then
she's a
strong confident feminine female
feminine woman right
you have to look at the girls individu
individually first of all
and then the other thing is are you the
kind of guy
for as for as often as for as much as we
talk about high quality women are you
high quality guy
who should be getting with the your
ideal confident woman in the first place
who takes care of herself
uh is definitely sexual is definitely
beautiful is definitely fit and makes
that a priority for herself
amongst many other things i've
constantly said this is that the reason
why
women are the way they are right now is
because they only have one value
and their only agency is their sexuality
if women want to be confident if they
want to find a guy in the future if they
want and
start early i will tell you the same
thing i told my daughter
start early and add value learn the
concept of value added
because if all you are is your cooter
that's all guys are ever going to see
you for
if all you're making money off of is
your only fan and showing your butthole
and online to everybody else
that's all guys are going to see you as
and once you get to be 29 or 30 they got
no use for you
develop more value whatever it is
right be a physical trainer like look
learn veterinary medicine i don't know
whatever it is
be hot be fun be easy ladies if you're
watching learn how to cook culinary
skills
all you have to do is feed a man
properly honestly that's probably the
most important thing well you know it's
funny to me
rich this this is an aside here but uh
what would be funny to me and i don't
know why more guys don't do this
you're going to complain about the fact
that you're you're you're well your
daughter right or your wife or your
girlfriend
and they don't cook and they don't know
how to cook you know what you do get
them a subscription to
um hellofresh and have them bring it in
and say
here you go you got 30 minutes make me
whatever this is i don't have to worry
about that man my girlfriend's a great
cook
and my daughter like she got up in the
morning on uh sunday like i do a show
with um
paul on this app called stereo at nine
o'clock you know she got up around 8 8
30. she's like hey daddy i want to make
some pancakes you know you want one i'm
like yeah
absolutely you know i'll take one real
quick i gotta get ready for the show
um you know so sometimes she's firing it
up i'll tell you what another thing is
that um
and i got this from dalrock uh right
around christmas time like there was
all these like feminists like jessica
valenti were writing these articles
about like
how horrible it was that women were
expected to wrap the christmas presents
right or to
be the hostess and it's so much stress
and so and why do we expect women to do
this and why do we expect
women to cook the thanksgiving meal and
and he brought up the fact that like for
when it comes to cooking cooking is an
act of love
it's it is uh i love you so much i'm i'm
concerned about your survival so here's
the food right here i'm going to make
you some good food and i'm in fact i'm i
love you so much
i'm going to figure out how to make some
very good food for you
so that you'll i mean that used to be a
value added for women was
you know maybe i'm getting a little fat
maybe i'm older but at least i can cook
better than these [ __ ] because i've
figured it all out
and it's it's really an act of
appreciating that person and i think one
of the reasons
and this is me spitballing here but i
think one of the reasons why women
refuse to cook for men is because the
feminist
prime directive is never do anything for
the express
pleasure of a man and cooking is one of
those pleasures
rolo i was at the um i was at the dojo
training and um
there was this girl there um on the
phone
[ __ ] stretching in front of us while
we're trying to train and it's like
she's on his [ __ ] call and she's
complaining about how i'm not gonna live
with no man that doesn't cook and clean
and i'm just like yeah that's why you
[ __ ] single [ __ ]
you get the point right yeah so you want
a wife not a husband yeah basically
you